hello and welcome to footnotes I'm here
to recap the most ravishing language and
ideas from the last week of Wired first
out today Greeks in space wired science
reported on the Curiosity rover getting
a shot of the Mars moon Phobos passing
in front of the Sun this moon is just 16
miles across and it's actually pulling
closer and closer to Mars it will crash
into the planet and around 50 million
years because all it ever wanted to do
was cuddle Mars never wanted anything
serious and now that the Curiosity rover
is there fo boss is totally jealous and
simply won't stand for it or it could
all just be the effects of gravity so
fobus get its name the greek
personification of fear and Marge's
other moon Deimos is the greek
personification of terror Mars itself is
of course the Roman god of war Phobos
and Deimos were brothers and sons of
Ares the Greek god of war you can
imagine this family kind of like the
father and sons from boondock saints
dealing with so shall it ever be only
less Irish faux boss is where we get
idea of a phobia a sometimes irrational
fear sure it can be reasonable like
arachnophobia but something like chroma
phobia what do they hear those colors a
little bit silly all the way not totally
inconvenient doable available there are
treatments for phobias such as therapy
and drugs or you can try something
called emotional freedom techniques
these consist of tapping yourself on
certain spots on your head and chest
preferably in a quiet place where nobody
can witness this or you can just take
your chances with phobia induced panic
attacks next up a great American hero
Inspector Gadget our gadget lab desk
reported on a new bluetooth bone glove
earpiece thing that you can use to make
calls with your hand just like in the
classic American cartoon Inspector
Gadget so this inspector gadget is a bit
like Inspector
kuzo in a sense they're both lousy
detectives yes so coming back yes bad
that did good think the hapless ness of
ace Ventura's only better dressed and
with fewer emotional and balances
inspector gadget is a cyborg which means
he's a human being with mechanical parts
like extendable arms and the hand fun
because he's a detective he starts each
episode by getting a message which
describes a mission while he reads it
his eyes make the sound of an old-school
teletype a long-distance pinner that was
obsolete by the time the show first
aired apparently the police department's
IT guys never got around to upgrading
the inspectors peepers in each episode
Inspector Gadget battles the evil dr.
claw inevitably foiled his plans and
then gives a public service announcement
these messages essentially told kids not
to do any of the silly stuff they had
just seen on the show another no
circumstances should they tried to
install helicopters in their heads an
inspector gadget assured kids with a
fear of colors there was a really dumb
idea to be watching cartoons in the
first place
you